so we have some pretty big geopolitics
to talk about today over the weekend
some Saudi oil facilities were attacked
and the Trump administration is
increasingly looking at Iran as the
culprit and before we get into sort of
like the specific analysis anytime in
the Trump era that we're doing an
analysis of geopolitics there's sort of
like the normal analysis one would do
based on the last 200 years of American
history and then you have to modify that
analysis to account for the fact that
Donald Trump is President of the United
States an analogy that came to me over
the weekend is sort of like if you have
an airline pilot that flies a particular
airplane right an Airbus 330 and you say
what is the take-off speed of the Airbus
330 and you have you're like in a vacuum
answer which might be a hundred and
fifty knots but then much like you have
to account for Donald Trump being
president in geopolitics you then have
to account for whether the runway is dry
or wet and what is the elevation of the
airport and other things and you might
end up with an answer where well in this
particular case the take-off speed for
an Airbus 330 is 160 knots when
accounting for these other factors and
similarly with Donald Trump thrown into
geopolitics we have to account for
Donald Trump in making our evaluation so
a few different things to go over it's
the event that took place the hypocrisy
from Donald Trump and also the growing
subservience by Donald Trump to the
Saudis which is something that we should
all be extremely worried about in
particular because of the connections we
already know Trump and Jared Kushner and
others around him have to the Saudis so
first of all why the focus on Iran so
far what we know is that a number of
Saudi oil facilities were attacked over
the weekend we have satellite images
that show 17 points of impact coming
from the north or the northwest which
could be Iran it could be Iraq
now in the immediate and the Iranian
backed Houthi militias are hootie
militias and never sure how to pronounce
that from Yemen claimed responsibility
and there are reasons to be skeptical
about this the direction of the attacks
is at least a potential reason to be
skeptical the use of cruise missiles
and drones seem to exceed the known
capabilities of the Hootie's and Donald
Trump as usual is reacting to everything
in the worst possible way
erratic indirect and sort of showing his
cards that he is indeed subservient to
the Saudis hypocritical subservience is
maybe how I would sum it up so first of
all Donald Trump tweeting Saudi Arabia
oil supply was attacked there is reason
to believe that we know the culprit are
locked and loaded depending on
verification but are waiting to hear
from the kingdom as to who they believe
was the cause of this attack and under
what terms we would proceed look at all
of the extremely disturbing elements
just to this one tweet hinting at Iran
but not saying it we have reason to
believe we know who did it why not just
come out and say it
locked and loaded it's a threat of
violence but again it's predicated on
Donald Trump having reason to believe
that he knows who it is but saying that
once the Saudis tell him who they
believe did it he's locked and loaded
and ready to go under whatever terms the
Saudis say are the ones that Donald
Trump should operate under this is a
level of subservience to the Saudis and
then we get to the hypocrisy because
Donald Trump in 2014
tweeted quote Saudi Arabia should fight
their own Wars which they won't or pay
us an absolute fortune to protect them
and their great wealth trillion dollars
of course Donald Trump was not present
at the time Barack Obama was president
at the time
so was that just BS and political
bluster probably the other possibility
is Donald Trump actually has made some
kind of deal with the Saudis for the
u.s. to be their protector and in a way
that deal has sort of been made in plain
sight for decades through American
foreign policy Donald Trump may well see
and it actually wouldn't be that crazy
he may see the endless and infinitely
growing arms deals with Saudi Arabia as
that sort of payment to the United
States for the protection
of the Saudis you may recall that when
Barack Obama sort of semi bowed to the
Saudis when they were greeting each
other the right went crazy even though
George W Bush was kissing the Saudis on
the cheek and they seemed fine with it
at the time now Donald Trump is saying
when the Saudis tell me who they think
did it and when the Saudis tell me what
the appropriate response would be we're
gonna go out and do it really strong
leader right projecting strength and
independence and focusing on what's best
for the oh wait no he's really not some
of the bigger political questions here
does Donald Trump want a war with
someone to help the arms industry is
that sort of what is at the core of
what's going on here does Donald Trump
want a war with someone so that he can
finally be the tough guy that he of
course is not but desperately wants to
be does Donald Trump want a war with
someone because he believes it will help
his reelection after all that would not
be incorrect in a sense I'm trying to
think of when the United States voted
out an incumbent president in the middle
of a war or significant military
engagement and I'm having trouble
thinking of that maybe there are
examples and or because this is all
obviously not just one thing it could be
a combination diss Donald Trump want a
war because it will be a distraction
from one of his many current or upcoming
scandals a combination is usually sort
of the right answer with this president
I got a lot of emails from the audience
over the last year saying David at some
point Trump is going to war the question
is who will it be against and under what
pretenses but the guy is going to find a
war one way or another either John
Bolton is going to help him or if John
Bolton is the impediment Bolton will go
which he since has and Trump will find a
war on his own maybe not more cynical
than reality actually suggests here and
of course immediately the economic
impact is significant relatively minor
in the context of the broader insanity
but oil price is spiking about one sixth
from sixty to seventy one dollars we
don't even get that much of our oil from
Saudi Arabia the notion that we are
dependent on the Saudis for the oil
itself is wrong I mean they have a big
market share
but from my recollection we get around
11% of our total oil consumption from
foreign countries and of that 11%
I think it's 9% only is from Saudi
Arabia so the actual numbers don't bear
it out but of course a massive player in
OPEC and in controlling the oil market
so an economic impact right away I don't
know where this will go we'll keep
following it I want to hear from you
about it but this is of course going to
be a very very crazy year leading up to
the November 20 2011